Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. This is part
eight of the clustered series.
A series in which myself and a guest
will attempt to fix broken Kubernetes clusters. The
catch is these Kubernetes clusters are broken by
members of the Kubernetes, we're cloud native, and
Rawkode communities.
Now before we begin today, we're gonna do
a little bit of housekeeping. First and foremost,
if you haven't clicked subscribe and click that
little bell on YouTube,
please do it now. It means you will
get notifications for all future episodes of clustered
and all the other cloud native content that
I'm doing. It also helps other people find
the content, which we can all agree is
a good thing. Right?
Also, there is an active Discord server. Feel
free to pop in there. There's currently a
discussed stage happened just now. Leo and Kevin
are there. Hey, and Kevin. Feel free to
go chat and laugh at us as we
attempt to fix these clusters. It's always funny,
at least for you.
Lastly,
I love to thank my employer Equinix Metal.
They provide the time, compute powers, and resources
for me to put this show together and
us all to have a bit of fun.
So thank you Equinix Metal. You can check
out Equinix Metal with Rawkode live as a
code. This will get you $50 in credit,
which is around one hundred hours of compute.
Alright.
Now today's guest,
Noel Georgie is joining us today, a active
Kubernetes community member. Hey there, Noel. How are
you?
Good.
Excited
and terrified too. Excited and terrified is exactly
where we need to be so I'm very
happy with that. Why
don't we start with a quick introduction? Do
you want to give us a little bit
about you and then we'll talk about today's
episode?
Nothing. Thank you. What we
yep. I work for an employer in a
company called Railsoft. It's a startup and we
do kind of like mostly for some of
the government contracts, mostly
in the defense department.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you very much.
We have our first question today, which I
think is is very apt. Is asking who
are the breakers?
I haven't. You guys want to know.
Yeah. I intentionally really not intentionally. I didn't
really post a lot of information about it
but we do have some really good breakers
today. We've got a cluster broken by Tim
Hawken,
one of the original or at least first
couple of contributors to the Kubernetes project and
Kubernetes
developer at Google Cloud.
The second cluster is broken by a
colleague of mine, Matt Anderson, who works at
Equinix Medal on our delivery and infrastructure team
spending all day with Kubernetes. And as he
assures me, he can break Kubernetes with his
eyes shut. So
I'm curious to see what evil things they
have done to our clusters.
Yep. I guess it's that time where we
just start taking a look. We will get
my screen shared now. Alright.
We're both on screen. We have teleports. I
believe you have access to it. I am
going
to start our first session. I will zoom
in a little bit. If you just want
to
jump into active sessions, click join and type
echo hello so we know that we're both
sharing the same terminal.
Yep. Got it.
Awesome.
That's a hard one though.
And in fact, there we go. We've got
a wave there from Matt who is watching
us. Thanks, Matt. I'm looking forward to this.
Alright. So we're starting with cluster 15. We
did them in numerical order. This is Tim
Hawkins cluster.
We will first
I'm gonna set as an alias so that
we don't have to keep messing that up.
I will export our cube config.
We're using the admin token
and
I'll give you the honors. You wanna type,
get nodes, get pods, whatever you want. Let's
see if we have an API server.
Why
does nobody ever leave us an API server?
Yeah. That's
Okay. Let's check that file.
Alright.
Lead the way, and I'll
Just want to see which API server it's
okay. It's
I guess it's IP of this machine.
Yep. It's this one. Right? 180 something.
Yeah. I think that's alright. It looks to
be what I would expect. I'm assuming our
API server potentially
isn't running.
Happy. Come on. It is running.
I hate it when that happens to it.
So let's check. Okay. It says the secure
port is 643.
Shouldn't
okay. The insecure port should be zero. This
is fine, but it's not responding.
Okay. So, yeah, we definitely have Do we
have Netcat here? Yep.
And
I just want to see. Okay. So it's
listening.
At least I can help reconnect to that.
I I'm curious if if we run the
get pods again and let it time out,
if it's gonna tell us HTCD connection timed
out or if it's gonna tell us something
else. I suspect
I mean, who would be harsh enough to
mess with HTCD? I made it very clear
my thoughts on people messing with HTCD. I
don't like people messing with Yeah.
Alright.
What's the timeout gonna be in thirty seconds?
Gonna be the longest thirty seconds of our
lives.
Yeah.
And if I'd while he jot down with
a comment there saying, wait. Wait. Wait. It
might time out with a message. Yes. I'm
I suspect we're gonna see entity.
Let's see. Just go through it, the
arguments to see if
are these user name handles normal?
I don't remember seeing them.
What do you not remember? Oh,
TLS handshake. No STD. I guess that's good.
Alright. Should we do some basic control plane
checks? Do you wanna
see if we have ETD running on the
PS table?
Yeah. Okay. Yep. It's running.
And
So Let's try that safety cheat first and
see if it actually works.
Yes. Hold on.
I really need to book oh, Oh. I've
found a new shortcut in my streaming software
that shows comments. That's useful but not what
I want right now. Okay.
I really need to start bookmarking this
because I use it all the time.
Great.
I'm I'm just trying. Yeah. I don't I
don't remember these at at city things. Oh,
happened?
We need
apt install.
Let's see.
Let's search.
It's a decline. Okay. Of course.
And we can just run.
Yeah. That looks good.
Yeah. That's good.
Yeah.
So
TLS handshake time out. That's gonna be one
of these weird error message that just phone
itself.
Oh, now you're getting scary. You know these
commands off the top of your head?
Yeah. I just I kind of use them
frequently.
And connect.
Lock the host.
Six o two three.
Oh,
right. Oh, I guess
it's really not listening.
So Good thing. It's lessening on ports six
four four three, but it's not actually running
TLS. Maybe that's what's happening here. Should we
go take a look at the
API server configuration?
Yep. Before that, let me check. Okay. It's
QA API server. I just want to know
if it's, any other process that's matched with
it.
Yeah. That would be sneaky.
Alright. Let's take a look at the
config. Kubernetes.
Ah,
so I don't get a full screen on
direct pro what what do it is?
Oh, yeah. We can just scroll up.
There we go. Okay.
I don't know. That's interesting.
We opened them and it started just halfway
down the file. It's as if maybe somebody
was sneakily in this file and didn't close
it properly.
So maybe that's a good indicator.
But let let's see what flags do we
have here in the API server.
Do you see the request
extra headers?
That's something
I had never seen them or I might
have missed it previously, but
You you would think I'd know most of
these arguments by now, but I must say
I just scroll over them looking for the
typos and swear words. Header,
it means, like, I think if you are
to authenticate, do you want to, like, pass
in those headers?
So you think these are suspect?
What is it? Like, friend, client?
I guess so. Let's try committing it out.
I had never seen them. I don't remember
seeing them previous cluster. So
Let's see if there's anything else here.
Look at that. Your media's a proper. It's
stroke view from spine. Yeah. Those look alright.
Probes, I'm gonna just skip over. Volume, spine.
You should take the time stamp. Yeah. I
I think
I think you're right. I'm not familiar with
these request header parameters.
So let's why don't we just get this
saved and
wait for the API server to restart and
we'll see what happens.
Let's see.
Sixteen o eight.
Two minutes ago? No. That's not restarted yet.
Right?
Yeah.
When did I sixteen
ten. Yeah. They've got it's not oh, there
we go. Okay. Restarting now. Okay. Took its
time.
You know,
always the telltale tale, but we can actually
see that all three of these files have
been modified in the last
oh, no. Wait.
No. It's it's it's the APIs ever have.
Okay.
Alright. So you wanna try? Yeah. Pods get
notes.
No.
So we don't have a comment from Leo.
Okay.
This okay. Yeah. Let's look at the comments.
So now we're probably Oh, so the word
was locked. Right?
Sorry. Can you say that again?
Oh, is it the comment about the verb
verbose logs? Yeah. Yeah. Leo suggested that we
pass in a couple of dash fees into
this and get some verbose log in. So
why don't we we do that with the
get nodes and we'll see if we get
any extra output. I suspect now that it
affects the weird request header thing that we're
gonna see an STD timeout. Oops.
Give
me minute. I just like it got locked
out.
Alright. I'll take over typing. Feel free just
to jump back in. Yep. Thank you.
I just pressed control w.
Oh, control w should work.
Oh, it just closed my tab, so maybe
it's on Linux. Oh, oh, yeah. That that
will be it.
Yep.
I'm just so used to that shortcut that
I always accidentally
Yeah. I've I've done that a few times,
especially when I was trying to work from
a Chromebook for a while.
That's painful.
Alright. We're still getting the TLS handshake timeout
on our
Do you remember what's the username?
No. I one. No one.
Okay.
Guess I'm gonna just have to work at
what we do next year. So
enter loading discovery information.
PLS handshake time out. Skip cache discovery.
At this point, I was kinda hoping to
see an SCD problem. Oh, you've just joined
the session because it did that weird reload
thing. I'm back.
There we go.
Okay. So you're because everything
taking too long to respond?
Yeah. But your open SSL command confirmed that
it was now listening on
a t l s o. Right? Listening on
643.
But,
normally, I would see, like, it returning certificates,
but I had never actually get a Kubernetes
API server. So
I could be like, it could be just
that Kubernetes API server is differently. I never
hit a Kubernetes API server with it.
I mean, like, I should return me the
certificate and everything so I can, like, go
and figure out
stuff anyway.
What did we get, please?
We got nothing. Leo said we should try
v equals nine
because Waleed suggested that earlier, but I can't
find that format. So
so what's happening? Oh, we got a thirty
two second time out
twice. Okay. So by
default, it only has the user agent headers.
I have never seen this ever before in
my life.
So while he suggested that maybe there's something
in between us and the API server,
I think that's a good call but we
we did run a netstat and we did
see that the API server process was
responsible for that port.
Okay. So So it could be something network
wise on the machine.
Is that what you're checking now?
Is there any oops. I just closed it
again. Give me that.
Okay. I'm back.
I will learn, but not to use that.
I'm wondering if there is any, like, IP
tables. Someone messed up with IP tables. Yeah.
Let's take a look.
Dash l, I guess? Yeah. Just doing l.
Let's get everything. Maybe we could grab it
for $6.04 $4.03.
Or maybe it might be named or something
or alias.
Yeah. Not really good with, like, people.
Oh, we're screwed then, aren't we?
Alright. Okay. So selling stuff I'm gonna mostly
ignore.
Don't.
I don't think
there's
an effort on toward there.
Yep.
That is my rather naive IP tables knowledge
shining through. But,
yeah, I think that's okay.
Let's take a minute. Let's take a this
that error message is
bugging me. It says it's looking up discovery
information as if it's maybe trying to verify
the CA somehow,
but
I'm not sure
what that means.
Let's see if they are left out as
any
hidden files or something. Hence
Do you wanna jump into the p t
I folder, and we'll see if any of
the time stamps look a little bit?
Sure.
The
Kubernetes. Yeah.
Let's
check that entity one.
Yep. That seems like a completely
different time stamp.
Oops. What did I do?
Pure
cert.
That looks different. Right?
Is it like the XCP pairing is not
working? And, like, it's not
Well, I think the XCP pairing must be
working. We've been able to well, we never
checked the health, but we did created a
the API.
Yeah. Let's try the x c d client
help thing. Yeah. Let's try it. We could
probably just do a control r, pull up
that last x c d command.
Health.
Do we do you remember what this is?
Nope.
Alright. Let's
Okay. And what 10 health. Yeah. That
seems healthy.
Yeah. I'm okay with that.
And I I like that requesting something from
the Kubernetes in a space seems to return
okay.
I I think I'd see to yourself. I
think we'd we'd see error messages.
Why don't we check the API server logs?
Maybe we should have done that five minutes
ago.
Less
cube.
Oh, come on. It is over dash.
Let's go to the end.
Don't see that end.
I'm just gonna do a quick scan, but.
I think, like, that points in the end,
but I don't know if it's actually an
issue. Which one?
Let me search through.
Endpoint.
Yeah. So something
yeah. It's over here.
Loaded.
I know. Let's see. Like, crap.
Nothing.
Yep.
This is something
I was unable to register. I think this
is fine.
Revolve that points from Kubernetes service. Do you
see that?
Yeah.
So do we
I think that's about, like, the node registration.
Right?
I think it's about node registration.
Can you ignore it for now?
Okay. I'll trust you.
Yep. From the previous I don't I don't
think this is anything useful here. Right?
So annoying.
Yeah.
What could we try? Like, we should change
the logs while hitting the AP server.
Alright. We'll tell you what. Why don't you
tell the logs and I will pop open
another
session.
Oh, there's an error message I can't error
now. Yeah.
Okay. So what have we got here? We've
got Yep.
Unable
to perform initial I o.
Yeah. There's an error.
Yep.
Probably we looked at the logs of the
old APA server.
It keeps
scrolling to oh, so annoying.
What's that?
Is that just one error?
I'm gonna open I'm gonna open this and
then because I can't.
Okay. Yeah.
Okay.
Where's the start of Yeah.
That's that's beefy.
Just keeps coming.
Okay. Okay. Loaded.
Loaded. Loaded. Normal. Normal. Normal. Normal. Oh, just
so these are all standard or, like, see
exactly STRs.
So it's probably is our results.
It says about endpoint.go.
Oh,
there's an HCD connection time out.
Just after that.
Some Okay. There we go. Okay.
Ah, authentication
handshake failed.
Yeah. We gotta contact that thing. It's speaking
to HCT. Okay. So we can speak to
HCT, but the API server cannot speak to
HCT. Fine.
So it's probably the certificate that I mentioned
in the manifest might be wrong
or messed up.
Okay. So we check the API server configuration
to make sure it's using the right certificates.
Oh, we got a etcdca
fail.
But the server, that's fine. I got the
cert and the key fail.
That looks right.
That's this thing that I show and I
was screwed through your head.
It does look okay.
And we It does look okay?
Keep it preferred service address, internal, external host
name.
Yeah. I think so.
I mostly run k three, so I'm really
don't want to, like, look into all this
stuff.
Let's
look into that folder and see.
It is TKI.
I need to add a new rule. Nobody's
allowed to touch it, CD.
The one that was modified was peer.crd.
Let's open up and see if it's Yeah.
But the peer search should really only be
used with other SEDs
to Yep.
But that was only one that seems like
has a different time stamp.
Oh, it might be that the service no.
But then we should see those errors in
the CD logs.
Yeah. Let's let's take a look at the
CD logs and make sure just even though
we run an endpoint's health, it looked okay.
I I guess we should have run an
endpoints list to make sure. In fact, there's
only one entity. This is a single control
plane node.
Yep.
Let's
maybe I should operate in there. Hey, Rich.
We do have some errors there. Right? Yep.
Lease is not fine.
Okay. So it became leader.
Oh, read only range request key.
Okay. It's an error. It seems like a
read only. But someone did actually see the
only.
And if it's read only, actually, this should
return data.
Okay. It seems like end of file server
name. Yeah. We're getting a rejected connection from
adder EOF server name blank.
Right.
Oh, let's check that.
Let's take that
admin.com
if it was modified.
I mean, it was not. No.
What else I could
add any ex like, add or remove any
extra information. Right? Authenticates
to
no. That should only be the API server.
Maybe we should like
Maybe we should just set this cluster on
fire. I don't know.
Hey. That's a good tip from Walid there
in the chat.
Wally says, why don't we get the request
headers back because those have been confirmed as
unrelated.
Yep.
So I think that's probably a good start.
I'm
really annoyed that we can create the entity.
I'm trying to think what could be
blocking
the API server and a t d.
Yeah.
Let's just double check these search a little
bit in here. Like
We
got Discord
chats in the bottom of my screen is
hidden.
Hit that. I have fixed it. Okay.
Okay. So we're advertising on our own IP
address, the 1454. That looks fine to me.
Authorization mode, node and RBAC. Yeah. Sure. Yeah.
That's fine.
Client CA, we're using the PKI directory. I'm
gonna assume that's fine.
They hadn't touched anything there.
Yeah. We've got the entities,
CFL and search key fail.
Yeah. Let's look at the
Maybe we need to look up this kubelet
preferred address types. Could that be
but then it's not the kubelet. Right? I
don't know.
I hate this cluster at all really.
Silly.
Can we restart?
Not yet. No. Few minutes behind. Yeah.
It's
taking forever. Yeah. I don't know why. We
can always carry it, I guess, but we'll
give another moment.
Usually, it's fast.
Okay. It's dead.
Okay. It's back.
Okay.
So can you try that open SSL command
again and see if we get a response?
Oh, it's connected. Okay. So we were chasing
our tails on that the first time.
That was yeah. That definitely was unrelated.
And then you said you would normally see
a certificate coming back. Is that right?
Yep.
I don't know if I
find disconnect.
Yeah. That's it.
And
now
since we hit it, let's go check the
logs.
L.
Which one is latest?
A l t.
Right.
Copy.
Code.
You see anything?
It seems like c setting the address to
CC. Right? It's just it's an STDR,
so that's what kind of follows me.
And are these actual studios?
Alright.
Who in the chat's got an idea?
So there was some ideas that potentially the
sound check timeout could be expired certificates.
Yep. We can check that.
I mean, we
I don't think the tech certificates will be
expired and the timestamps haven't changed on any
of them.
Alright. So that we are not set.
I can check the expiry of that set.
Yeah. That's it. I know.
I'm glad you know how to check it.
I'd be on Google looking up the open
SSL command again.
No. It's a little x c d.
That was the peer dot cert. Yeah. Dot
cert
dash
text.
That's fine.
And I can actually type dash and take.
Right. Yeah.
Oh, I don't need text to that.
Okay.
It's April 6.
Yeah. That looks good.
And it's created when I expected it. That's,
you know, that's when I spun up the
cluster.
That tells me that
I mean, it has been modified,
obviously, but not the expiry date.
Yeah. It's not expired.
Yeah. I actually should have not expired. Would
be just not just bring it out after
a water. Yeah.
That's fine. Wow.
A hard one indeed.
Let's
oops. Sorry.
Let's run a PSC. I wanna see if
there's anything running on this that I don't
expect to be running.
Yep.
All normal.
NTP SSH.
NCT.
Speakers from metal l b,
filter.
Alright.
You see anything suspicious?
Nope.
I
don't even see a firewall running.
Let's just double check.
Status firewall
d.
And that won't that won't be fire. Yeah.
USW.
Yeah. That's the one that's out there.
It all looks
fine. We went through the IP tables.
We're not the ways to prevent a service
from responding is, like, they call c freeze
the c groups. But, like, since we restarted,
it should not bother it. So this must
be something else.
Yeah.
I hate this.
I hate that I'm relying now on modified
dates. Just The bold actually, the folder time
stamp is
shady.
Sorry. Say that again. It's easy.
Actually folders timestamp. Right? It says, like, ten
sixteen twenty six. That's the only thing that's
come kind of different.
Make sure what we're looking at is legit
as well. I'm just gonna make sure there's
no crazy amount of business going on.
Yeah. I don't think they're hiding
anything from us here.
Yeah. Okay. So
Sorry. Were you gonna type? Off you go.
I'm gonna read there again. I think what
we'll do is we'll give this one another
four minutes and then we'll move over to
the other cluster and then if we have
time we'll look back but I think Tim
may have actually clustered us.
Yep.
I I I just don't under it's
gotta be something so silly. Right? Because we
can run etcd.
Yep. And the edit might be something so
silly.
Endpoint.
Let's hit endpoint status too.
Let's do this.
I SCD is
is fine. Like Fine. We exported a whole
bunch of things. In fact, let's just look
at the cheat sheet. Right? So the certs
that we're using are
the CA
oh, that's just the health check ones.
I wonder if we point it to the
other search if it works or fails. Yep.
That's a good point. Okay. So let's
the CA doesn't change, but these two will.
So that is underscore set and underscore key.
Let's see what keys we've got.
So let's try
this one and go with
which one's the API server you're using?
Server one? Server dot server. Right?
Yep.
Let me open up a new session. Can
I join?
You can create a new session if you
want yet. Fire away. Alright. Let's try endpoint
status.
Yeah. It's still alright. That's fine.
Let's check if it's actually using this file.
We didn't really check which file it was
using.
Oh, sorry. I need to go. I'm gonna
type.
So Leo's asking,
is the breaker around for hand? No. I
think Tim is in meetings and cannot join
us live. Well, I'm sure he will take
great pleasure in laughing at us
later.
Okay. It was the wrong side we used.
It's it's it's
API API server, actually, decline. Yeah. Okay. Let's
let's hook it up to that. Give it
one more spin before we move on to
Matt Henderson's cluster.
API.
API server
at c d client dot
cert.
And let's see if it's a key, I
guess.
Yep.
K. K. So let's see client dot key.
Run a status as well. Just
okay.
Yep. It's working fine. So
nothing Let's easy there.
Let's take us through it. Everything
we're doing manually is working.
What is standing between our API server and
etcd? The API server has started as a
static manifest
running in a container.
We need to look at that API manifest
again.
Do you agree? Sure.
Yep.
Oops.
Sorry.
Alright. That's always the fun part. Okay.
So
let's check the image.
I'm gonna I wonder if he's brought in
a sneaky image.
Like I guess he could have replaced the
image with
with anything with it at present.
I don't even know. Is there a way
to know if that image pulled at all?
I don't know.
Four minutes ago, so it's not restarted yet.
Let's give that a minute. If that doesn't
help Yep. We'll jump onto cluster two and
then if we have time, we'll jump back.
But
I'm at a loss.
So impatient.
I'm gonna restart. I thought there must be
something in between these two, some component that
we are not aware of or, like, something
how it communicates with HCD,
or it must be some flag that's causing
this.
Okay. And let me
I think the cache discovery is fine. Okay.
But it says DLS handshake timeout.
Let's take that off.
That curl in verbose mode.
Wait.
Oh, but it's really was responding
and
So success Oh, do you see that?
It's saying TL is 1.3.
Is that bad?
Probably. Let's check that city manifest and, like,
see if it's actually only listening on p
l s 1.3.
Okay. I we could have tested it. But
if I said, yeah, whatever.
No. The NCD manifest.
Oh, the NCD. And probably the NCD CTL
might just work fine with TLS 1.3.
I know. It might be that just curl
used it by default. Like, it should have
been, like, tried using the fallback mechanisms,
whatever.
I don't believe it should appear.
I think that's okay.
So why would TLS 1.3 be a problem?
As the API server doesn't like that, I
can just quickly verify that. I might be
sometimes we might be just oops. Not this
one.
You think it's maybe restricted to 1.2?
Yep.
Okay. I think it's just PLS 1 2.
Oh, come on. Is that
sorry.
Day on beach.
It's after connect.
I don't
know, but
I know, like, we can pause and maybe,
like I don't know.
That's what I usually do. I don't have
it. Yeah. I don't think we have it.
Oh, it's DashTLS1Underscore2.
Of course, it is.
Why?
It's connecting, but I don't know why it
doesn't return the certificates. Like, it's viewed.
Alright.
You
Google
and, like
right. Like, it usually returns. Did I type
it wrong?
See, it just returns all this bunch of
data, which
makes me, like, like, verify that actually kind
of thing. But this is, like
right. This is what's kind of bugs me
off. Like, it doesn't show anything.
And if I do TLS one three,
let's see if it does something
just to verify. Ah, nothing. This is what
kind of confusing.
It should return those.
Okay. Let's
I don't wanna spend too much time on
it when we're not sure, but
let's try the IP address
instead of local host just
to rule out a couple of things. So
Oh, yeah.
Take off that protocol.
Yeah.
It's connecting, but it's not responding. I think
it respect to
So what would stop it? Certificate.
What could stop it responding?
I let's take the manifest again. It might
be that f certificates are not mentioned for
the API server. We could always bust out
TCP dump.
Wait.
Where is the certificates for the Kube API
server itself?
Do you think we're missing something from here?
I guess so.
Oh, there is TLS cert file.
So at cKubernetesAPIAPIserver.crp.
Let's take the things that expired.
Mean, the timestamp on them hadn't changed.
Yeah. But I think it's Yeah. Maybe maybe
on the, like, maybe unlikely.
I didn't pass the fly.
Let me find the
what were
oops.
Add intake.
Yep. It's eight or six. That's fine.
Beautiful.
It's fine. It's not even touching.
Permissions looks fine.
Why?
Something funny that locking it on. Like the
API server is obviously getting a request. It's
getting accepted and connected but it's unable to
respond to anything that we send to it.
Got my c dash view.
It's not responding.
That's a problem. So it's Well, it might
be responding. It it's just not getting to
us.
That's the thing. Right? It's like Yeah. Probably.
But, like, if you see, right, it sends
a hello, but the server now responded with
the what, like, I don't know what to
write. It does something with TCP. Yeah.
Like
so it's just like client is sending the
hello, but, like, the server is not responding.
Alright. Let's call it. Like, I don't we
we can't spend the full episode on this.
We'll come back to it.
Yeah.
I I'm at a lot right now. Let's
let's see what we can do over 16.
So
this cluster,
I've just joined and created a session. Please
just feel free to join that type echo
hello. Login.
This cluster is broken by Matt Anderson.
He leads our Kubernetes team at Equinix Medal.
I will set up
our alias.
I will set up our cube config.
And I will run again pods.
We actually have an API server.
Fake.
The
grep
be running.
Rawkode and Seth is
Lots of things are unhappy.
Maybe get get pods was the wrong idea.
What what about nodes? Okay. We have three
not ready Oh, it's not ready. Unhappy nodes.
So I guess our work in the control
plane is done. We're gonna need to jump
over
to the workers.
So let's jump onto the first one. Yeah.
That's might be easier.
Are sessions created?
I can't connect to the workers.
Wow.
If I can't connect to the workers, we
can't debug.
Okay. Not matching UUID like target.
What's that?
I will attempt to SSH manually,
which is not
good because we can't share screen.
At least we'll know if anything's running on
those machines.
Okay.
So
I was able to SSH on the worst
curve, but that means teleport is maybe just
broken. So I'm gonna just try and restart
the agents.
We'll see if those come online.
Let's try restarting it.
Yep.
Not looking good.
There are very few rules on custard, but
breaking teleport is one of them.
Yep. You should not.
Alright. That's not coming back even though we
have teleport running, which tells me there's potentially
network issues.
But we can't share a terminal. Let's
Yep.
And I get it angry.
I get it flustered.
Let's do that.
Alright.
We're gonna have to try and fix the
networking rules then.
Let's pull up the teleport
network
ports.
That's not gonna work.
Oh, wait. There was the admin thing there.
Not very useful.
Let's see.
Just need some port numbers.
Alright. There we go.
So
we've got
pretty much the three zero two range as
used by
teleport. Let's take a look at our IP
table rules on this worker.
Those look fine.
Okay.
Let's just use the control plane node right
now and see
at least if the workers are okay, we
SSH down on my local machine. I restarted
teleport. It actually seems to be okay. So
let's just try and work from the control
plane node and see if we can work
this out. So
IP tables
dash l.
Let's see.
Oh, I can join. Right? Yeah. Yeah. You
can join the the
control plane node on cluster 16. Let me
know. I've set I'll keep an eye on
it, but you should see when you pop
in here.
Okay. Must be on the wrong session.
Okay. I see it.
Yep. I just reload. It's got a weird
bug when you join that it just, you
know, freezes my screen.
Okay. So let's run that IP tables again.
I'm gonna ignore all the Cyllium stuff because
if Teleport can't reach over the back end
network, then I think our IP tables are
being messed with.
We can ignore WP
running.
I'm gonna check the firewall.
Yep.
I think it's just UFW. Right?
I think so. Yep.
It's just like UFW enabled. I don't know
if it's a system to service. Whatever. Yeah.
It's not running.
You see anything?
We do have Matt watching, I think. He
did leave us a comment earlier.
So at least if we Yeah. I have
a coworker who is, like, very expert in
networking. So whenever I hit a networking issue,
I just, like, ask him. He sends you
some commands. I just run it. Send him
the output. Tells me what to do.
These look alright.
I'm not
accept all.
Alright. So let's just let's try let's try
in them.
We're just the noise.
Actually, dash l doesn't list out everything. There's
something else that actually shows you everything else.
I don't know what does that like. One
like, I don't go running that once.
So this is a drop policy,
but it says it's for marked packets.
This is only doing local host
that's invalid.
Okay.
So whatever is affecting teleport is probably affecting
is probably the reason the nodes can't speak
to the API server.
So let's run a test.
K.
One four
seven.
Nope. 14.
1 4 5. Okay.
So 145. Yeah. This is the IP address.
So while it is asking from
the Yeah. Why we're not checking the the
network policies. The reason I'm not going straight
to that is because Teleport is effective and
Teleport runs directly in the operating system.
So
I'm not fussed about checking the Kubernetes policies
yet. Maybe that's naive of me. What do
you think?
But I think if we could if we
fix Telethorpe yeah.
I don't think that Kubernetes policies affect
nodes.
It can't write. It's only affecting the overlay
that, okay, Kubernetes manager. So Yeah. I don't
know.
I'm gonna try it. But my overlay yeah.
Carling six four four three.
Let's take for.
Yeah. There there's something in between
us and that machine.
Let's make sure I can even
hang it. Let's use the private IP address
too. Yeah.
Oh, they do.
The
post network policy.
Yep. Let's see if those things exist
yet.
CRDs.
Alright. There's something we learned today. Thanks, Matt.
Post network policies.
Do
get API resources? From API. Yeah. Yeah.
API resource.
What did I do?
It's not get. I think it's just keep
control API resource. Oh, yes. Just, yeah, API
resource.
Did
you mean yeah. Just do it.
Both.
You may wanna do a green dash I
maybe.
Yes.
Try a Selium cluster wide. Oh, okay. It's
probably Selium cluster wide network policies.
It says cluster wide, and then the other
is, like, CDM,
like, policy. So let's try get CCNP.
Wait.
It's very hard for me to.
Ah,
see?
Wow. I didn't know about this. This is
cool.
Yeah. New to me as well.
Let's let's describe them, take a look at
them before we go sledgehammer
deleting them. Oh.
Yep.
I have no idea that Kubernetes could modify
the That's
cool. Let's do it egress.
And
this is something I learned from Duffy.
Alright. Let's see what we have here.
Oh, it doesn't really. We probably need to
get the YAML.
Yeah. We can take a look at do
get old YAML too on it. Why not?
But it looks like we've got some sort
of egress to the world. I'm assuming world
is special for everything.
Spec
kind.
Okay. Two entries,
a word.
What does it say? It's, blocking.
It
shouldn't be a stack. It shouldn't be. Egress,
two entities, world, and what is the kind?
Is it, like, cluster or white network policies?
And this one was egress.
Is it, a default thing?
Well, yeah. Potentially,
why don't we do a kubectl
explain CCNP
spec?
What's the is it dot spec?
Yeah.
That's not They don't really have a description.
I say we delete them.
Valid. Yes. Yes. Yes. Thank you, Valid. Yeah.
World not equal to cluster. Wow.
World does not even cluster.
Come on.
Okay. Let's do CCNP.
Are we happy just to delete these? There's
not nothing nothing good of these ever came.
Right? Anyway, it's not clustered, so it can't
be like the default one. Right? Well, I
will delete the egress, and then I'm gonna
describe
CCNP.
I just wanna
see what that pretty much is.
This one,
ingress from the world. I'm assuming these are
just blocking all ingress and ingress traffic.
Yep.
Clust oh, custard
ingress.
See, I love it when we get a
break like that where we learn something. That's
that's the best thing.
So do we think
that That's tech telephone.
Look at that. We got one back there.
Yep. I'm assuming the other two are gonna
come back on momentarily
depending on the retry pause. Bullshit.
Come back soon. Yep. It's getting ready.
I hate it when I get taunted.
Matt is saying
it's not gonna be that easy. So let's
see. Did the yeah. The the notes are
coming back. So let's check if Celeum. Do
you wanna do a namespace Celeum get pods
and see if our networking is slowly starting
to come back to life?
Ah, so one of the nodes is still
not ready. I assume it would eventually be
ready. Yeah. Let's give that a few minutes,
but let let's check out the Celeum namespace.
What is pending? Getting there. Yes. We've got
two agents online, which means two of the
worker Yep. I think that's the one that's
scheduled on, but, oh, that's not ready.
Yeah. We could just do Dash 0 Pike.
And oh, come on. It's a little bit
hot read.
DP4.
Yeah. It's the one that's not ready.
So it's like maybe that's a breaker.
Yeah. I think we may have to get
Yeah. That's I'm gonna jump on that note.
Let's take a look. So t t j.
And then we don't have teleport access. I'll
just need to grab the IP address and
jump to my terminal for a second. We'll
do some Okay. Teleport is still on.
Is it back?
No. Okay.
Let's see if we can just encourage it
to pop back so we can use our
shared terminal. So BSSH.
And I will just do a restart
teleport and while I'm here,
I'll try a kiblet.
Why not? Like, who knows? It could just
be that simple.
Is teleport happy? Let's try hitting the API
server using code and see if it pops
up.
Alright.
Yep.
I'll do that.
It teleports back on that node. How's the
get
the cubelets start back yet?
My flakes still got go.
So Matt told us to note the IP
address and the node list. So let's do
a get nodes or wide and see if
there was something issue there.
What do we got?
The one that is not ready has, like,
25145.
Is that the one you're on?
That's okay.
Yep.
I'm on that machine. Right? So
yeah. The teleport came back.
IP address.
Excuse me.
Yeah. 145.
Let's check the kubelet logs. So
journal
kubelet.
Oh, okay. We got errors.
Dial. Oh, it's just failing to connect to
API server. Right?
Yep.
Connection timed out.
Okay.
Why is it to do the connection timing
or or everything today?
Yeah. No. Everyone just seems to be
targeting our networking knowledge.
Alright. Let's see what we got in IP
table. Although my scanning of this previously did
not do me any good whatsoever.
So
Maybe there's like something hidden again.
I
should get better at this networking nonsense.
Yeah.
Ephelia.
But maybe it's yeah.
Let's assume that the control plane or at
least something and cut
let's assume Matt's
doing something with Celeium and other cluster resources.
Maybe we should just do a cube control.
What do you see? See
there are, like, a lot of Celeum network
policies.
Oh, yeah. And it's
blocking in the namespace cube system, so I
guess it might be blocking it for that
node.
Thanks for the confirmation there, Matt. He has
confirmed that everything was done using Kubernetes.
Awesome.
Means we can stick to teleport. Oh, thank
you.
So you've pulled up the cellular network policies.
We've definitely got those custard egres and ingress
things again.
So you wanna
yeah. Good call.
Right.
Node
specific stuff Yep.
It has some selected. Let's delete it.
I love this sledgehammer approach. Just just delete
anything. In fact, I should just write a
script that looks for any changes to the
system within the last three days and just
delete them all. Although, maybe that will get
me in trouble. Like some of the monitoring
tools should do like once you deploy cluster,
it should monitor the state and if anything
changes, it should just go back.
I think it's actually I should run something
on the cluster that audits every API server
request so that I can replay it later.
Let's let's for now let's go with the
sledgehammer, delete anything we don't know and see
if we can get this cluster working again.
So that was one of those really cool
CNI plug ins and technologies that there's just
so much of it that I've not really
even started to play with enough of the
cool features in network policies. Although we do
have Hubble on our cluster.
Wonder if we should port forward to it
and show Hubble.
Because that would probably that would actually show
us I think all the policies right in
front of us.
Hold on. Let's let's try that.
DLB cluster. This is 16.
Export.
Okay. Should I delete things or wait for
Yeah. Just give me two seconds. Let's Yeah.
Let's yeah. Let's check the Huddl. I had
always checked that. I want wanted to deep
dive in my cluster, but, like, never got
around it.
Oh, Hubble was here.
Oh, what's the debug pod?
Where's Hubble?
Let me check if I just failed. Did
I not enable Hubble?
Hubble enabled.
Okay. I think Hubble was taken away from
us.
I see. Either that or it's not.
It could be on that node or no.
Could we see it as pending? Alright. Let's
just delete. Let's go.
Alright.
And
get
notes.
I can
I can gently encourage that kubelet to restart
too? So
t t j or was it another one?
No. T Alright.
Restart.
Yep. It's
Yep.
Come on. K.
Keep it as restarted.
I I guess we should delete all of
them because if you look at each, right,
it seems like hundred minutes. So probably
maybe some time back.
Right? Sorry. What was that?
So if you look at each of all
these policies, right, it's just created, like, a
hundred minutes back, but, like, the node is,
like, two days old. So probably all these
probably passing stuff.
Yeah. They're all two hours old.
Yep. Should I go and, like, delete everything?
I mean, it may get us in more
trouble, but I fully support your approach. Let's
do it.
Yep.
And this is my favorite thing.
Nice.
Alright.
I will restart the cue ball just in
case it needs a little
push.
Yep.
I'm gonna try to familiar with, you would
know, like, which one are the default.
That's, like, kind of a drainage.
Damn you, Where are you?
Alright. Let's get the logs for it again.
Yeah. Let's check the logs or, like, try
calling log. It's
telling me we're still getting a connection time
out on it.
Okay. So those are okay. Those are, like,
root log. We could ignore.
I love Matt's comments. I was procrastinating,
and I only broke it five minutes before
the stream.
And then five minutes, she's still got us
chasing her tail. So thanks a lot. Right.
Let's see.
Is there anything else with Serium?
Yeah. I would do a Oh, Serium. Resources
and grep to start. They've got all complete
in our mind.
Yeah.
Like, this is, like, why it's, like, autocomplete.
Okay. So let's Oh,
okay. There are some endpoints
which are named clustered.
Oh, no. It must be from the ports.
These are from the ports and the default
namespace that I was given an IP address
too. So that looks good.
Alright.
We checked network policies and customer by network
policies endpoints.
Let's choose the same nodes. That looks
yeah. I think that's standard. Just try this.
Matt says, if we burn the policies, we're
on to our next fun adventure. So we
got something else to do.
Yep.
And I assume it's probably based on CDM.
Let's check for the old classics. Right? Let's
check for a mutating webpack controller,
any validating webpack controllers. Let's see if there's
anything interfering with node registration.
Nothing.
I don't see this card. No.
You're dating that for configuration.
Damn it. Okay.
Let's check the
API server configuration and see if there's any
static admission controllers enabled.
Oh, yeah.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, I thought you did a control w
there, but you said alright.
Yeah. Those haven't changed. Yeah. I was going
to, but I don't know. But I saves
all the files none of the files that
I did.
Alright. So Matt has definitely used only cube
control, which means we're dealing with resources. Let's
Yeah. Let's let's go down this
rabbit hole.
Alright. Let's let's do a get pods all
and just make let's see what it let's
grab for dash v running and see what
we've got still pending.
Wow.
Alright.
Rawkode is pending, which
I'm not really worried about. Oh, Cognitive is
terminating.
Okay.
So But it shouldn't affect
the node registration.
Must be missing something.
If you type that Oh, we haven't actually
checked the node resource.
I wonder if he's just modified it.
Could that stop it registering?
No. Like, if you look at the logs,
right, it's still connected issue.
Can we check the latest logs?
From the Kubernetes? From the Kubernetes? Yeah. Yep.
I've got them here.
We're just seeing the connection time out.
I use the connection time out. Kubit node's
not synced.
Failed to watch the node. Is that IP
the right one?
90 three one one eight.
I think so.
Yeah. The IP address is fine.
Yep.
518.
Alright. Matt's given us all the hints here,
so that's good.
That's something to do with IP v four
address. So let let's go back into that.
I've got the machine here. Right? What are
we expecting?
It's useless.
14Dot5.
Dot 5. I feel like
Yep. The
CDR?
Wait.
This is wrong. The Sillyum host. Right?
This IP address is just flat out
wrong because that's the pod network.
I wonder if we drop in the
10 dot address here. That alright? Think I
got But let's let's be fine. Before
I go change it, I was No. That's
like a working note. Yeah.
The amount of times I've made this worse
for myself by modifying something that I shouldn't
touch.
Oh, no. That's got the same. Okay.
Podsider, Podsider.
I've got a status here with the address.
So let's confirm that.
Maybe we should just print these to file
and def them actually. Let's do that.
Okay. So this is our broken.
Yep.
Yep. That's what I usually do.
Yeah. I've definitely made I just like always
save the YAML before usually I always save
the YAML before deleting in my stuff just
to be safe.
I
can't type. I'm gonna reload.
Hold on.
Okay. Oh, just type in reset. Like, whenever
this happens, like, if you type in reset,
it, like, fix the prompt. Oh, nice.
Yep. Just type in reset. Like, sometimes some
applications messes up with output. Just type in
reset. Like, you won't see that, like, you're
typing it in, but it should fix it.
Okay. So let's get notes.
K. Get notes.
Drop in a working one. Dash o o
g m o.
Working.
And then our broken one.
I miss the plug in. Like, I have
a lockout plug in, like, called qcutl neat.
So I always pipe output of minus o
YAML to qcutl neat, which should remove all
the unwanted stuff. So it's easier to test.
It's like a nice tool. Nice.
I'll check that one out.
Okay. Let's see what we've got.
Besides a really crappy diff, but
not worried about this. No. Let's not worry
about all of these. This is not I
think you're really want. Those are, like,
I just go go to the top.
All the data. Okay. The pod CD. Oh,
what is the pod CD? Was there, like,
a definite?
192. Yeah. It's more that each each node
has this on pod side. Yeah. I would
expect that. Yep. That's right.
Alright. And the only
difference was with the annotations. Right? Those are
still annotations.
Sorry?
Can you diff it again? Oh, yeah. Sure.
Alright.
So it says CLMHost921683653171.
Oh, wait.
That all seems like a little bit weird.
Like, doesn't match up. Right? Like, one is,
like, dot three and another is dot seven.
That's like it goes like
I'm not sure if it's like a c
n thing.
Yeah. I think it's allocating its own
network to each node and each pod gets
its own address space. I think that's alright.
Okay. Let's take that CCM by second. Yeah.
Celium.
Celium by Fic.
I'm curious, Matt. Did you kill Hubble?
It's really annoying me that we don't have
Hubble. Oh, look at that.
Wow.
The classic table approach.
Yep.
See if there's anything else in here.
It should like once the series is over,
like, you should probably write a book, like,
100 ways to break Kubernetes clusters.
Alright. Let's fix both of those. I think
10 I think it should be 10 slash
16.
Not
a hundred.
No. Probably, like, try restarting the cube like
yeah.
That started.
Oh, no. It's not.
Oh, wait. Is it? Yeah. No.
Direct it?
Yeah. That's not starting. Damn it.
Disabled.
It's yeah. That's.
Matt says our CIDRs are wrong. I think
we just fixed that.
Right?
Or
is it, like, a wrong one?
This I assume this is a cluster c
a d r.
Yes. Thanks, Pop. I hope you're enjoying our
suffering here.
No. I don't want Pop mentioned he needs
to go for me.
Right. Okay. Let's go through this.
There's gonna be something here. So
the were insiders were 1000Slash16.
We think that was wrong. We set it
back to 1000016.
If we could verify from the working cluster
oh, I know what that was. We don't
have a working cluster.
Tim Hawkins cluster is permanently destroyed.
In fact, I have the Cilium config map.
Do I? Yeah. Let's take the local one.
Yeah. I might be able to.
Yeah. Probably, like it'd be, a different one.
Anyway I know we use the
let's see.
Oh, should we restart the CD ports
after Oh, yeah. Yeah. If we haven't reset
yeah. Of course. We have to restart the
CuteProttle,
rollout,
restart.
Just being nice.
You have people with your rollout restarts. I
generally just go for the delete approach and
let Kubernetes do it. I used to do
that, but after watching, like,
Jason doing it, I couldn't, like this seems
like more
Wait. Okay. It must be like a stateful
set. Right?
Honestly,
k dash n, solium, get paused, delete all,
like.
I don't know. It must be. Celeum is
a demon set. Okay. Yeah. I should be.
The deployment is oh, yeah. So the operators
are deployed, but we need to restart the
agent. So restart the demon set Celeum. Yes.
Celeum. Yep.
Matt
has thrown out some more tips. He's taken
absolute pity on us and saying if I
look at my helm values,
my pod cider starts with one name two.
So let me pop that open again.
So has that been changed in the config
map? Native. Oh, of course. Yeah. Native written
cider. I've set it to 1000,
which is stupid.
192168.
But we need to modify our our config
map again.
Thanks, Matt. So our cluster pool IPV four
should be 192168
as well.
It'll need to be a yes. Dot zero
dot zero slash sixteen.
Okay.
You're probably yeah.
Other one should be where are you?
And then we're ready to roll out. Roll
out.
Yep.
And there was one more roll out. That's
three. It's just the So
I The Equidix metal private IP foresider is
actually
ten
dot.
If we if if we tell Cillium to
work on that space, I'm surprised more bad
things didn't happen.
Look at that. We've got them all.
Do you wanna run get notes?
Yep.
Hold on. I'm gonna restart that kubelet that
kubelets.
What is the debug
board doing there? Let's delete that.
I don't know. People like to leave me
little presents on cluster, I've noticed.
Delete board.
Alright. I restarted that kubelet.
And it deleted the Deepak board.
But if it was an actual cluster, like,
if I see something like that, I would
always, like, find like, describe, see the YAML,
find the image, get the old file system,
save it somewhere, and, like, inspect it later
on. It's fun to do such things.
Right here, just the update.
Okay. Must be
yep.
Let me see if it's a deep pipeline.
Nope. I think my thing is that weird.
Let me refresh.
Did we have all all the nodes? Then
we will go, oh, we don't have all
that.
Not yet.
That's it. We will have lost the game.
And meantime,
I just want to see why those ports
are
not terminating.
It's kind of stuck.
Serial f w.
So we're still getting,
oh, we're getting a lease adder.
No. It's still a timeout. Right?
Oh, yeah. I missed that. Okay. I was
too busy reading this. Okay. So we're still
getting a timeout here.
It says terminating,
but it's not terminated.
And why is its priority, like, too high?
Where? I did.
Priority.
No. That's fine, I guess. Like, let's just
get the pods. But it's, like, still terminating
for, like, some Yeah. I'm gonna
gently encourage that. Yeah.
Chris, period.
Period. I can't.
Although, it's actually this is the one that's
on the Kubelet node that can't connect. So
that it's not even gonna terminate anyway.
Oh, yeah. K. Got it.
Just.
Yeah. So that's pending. Yep. Right? And because
we don't have a kuplet, it's
stuck there.
Okay. Let's describe
the node
again.
Wow.
That is cool. I'm
just gonna keep looking at the cubelet logs
and hope that something pops up.
In
fact you know I'm gonna stop it through
system D and I'm gonna maybe
I'll start it.
Matt says there there we go, but I
don't know. Oh wait.
The Wally doesn't matter to us to check
the Kubernetes service.
But the service wouldn't explain why our Kubelet
can't
connect. Right? Or is there Kubelet connect that
something's broken
even though it's speaking to the server? Hold
on. Let me see if I can get
an actual error. Has an endpoint said it's
oh, wait. Its endpoint is wrong. Right?
The endpoint should be
93118.
Yep.
And it's 127.
Well, that's the control plane's other IP address.
That should also work.
Oh, okay. Okay.
So we have a Oh, the target one
is wrong. Right? It says 123.
Oh, yeah.
But I still don't think that explains why
our Kubelet can't speak to the API server.
But what? Yeah. I don't understand, like, why
the service should affect it. Right? Like, it
just radically
hits the
and the target bot should be
6443.
Matt, same. We're looking right at it.
Yeah. Matt, you'll find out soon enough that
when you're on the stream, you're looking at
a lot of things and it's it's
it's difficult.
I guess it's 6443.
Right?
Yeah.
I
Yeah. It is.
Alright. It says 6443. Alright. Like, we could
like to queue port forward and, like, see.
And
there's the node.
I
hate this queue.
No. We're still getting a tame out. And
I don't think that's really easy to the
surface. This is something else. Yeah. But it
must be something different. Yeah.
Wait. I'm gonna restart it one more time
because, you know, I feel like I'm gonna
another circle.
So starting speaking to container d.
What was the very first error message?
Yeah. It's still a connection timeout on the
right IP address.
I'm just gonna
try this with curl again.
Yeah. I I just I can't get to
that note.
All the same stuff we're going.
But I don't I don't yeah. It can't
be the service. There must be
I'm gonna try and just make sure. Let's
see.
Just I get it from my local one.
Point 40 five.
Oh, alright.
No. On you go. Oh, it's not even
pinging. I was typing to yeah. It's I
can't even ping the private address.
I don't know if this is part of
Matt's
break or just completely unrelated.
Can you ping that IP address? Do you
wanna try a ping 1025141?
So 1025.
40 1. Right? 14.
No. Wait. That's that's not our computer.
Let me read out from here.
Try
pinging
ten twenty five fourteen dot five.
Nope.
Alright. And just for clarity, let's try and
ping one of the other machines. So let's
try pinging
4 143.
Right. Yeah. It does.
I think this is unrelated.
The I think, like, traffic both of these
is blocked. Right?
Yeah. But Matt said he only used kubectl.
And if I can't even ping the private
I p v four address,
that's a problem and not the one I
think Matt's given us.
Oh, maybe we should just ignore that for
now. Have we gotten the cluster healthy besides
that that machine?
Oh, yeah. We should. If did, let me
just
Yep. It does connect. Yeah. That's right. So
oh, it's terminating. It's prop okay. The other
one is running. So and the Postgres, it
probably like, if it delete and it gets
rescheduled on the Yeah. If we force delete
Postgres, I reckon that'll restart on a node
that works. I think we just got unlucky
and had some other random
networking problem. And remember I said when we
set the native pod CIDR to 10 dot,
I was surprised that more things didn't break.
Well, I think maybe that's what's happened.
I just created my password from my clipboard.
Oops.
I have done that before. Don't worry.
It's fine. It's just for this episode, so
it's, like, a temporary thing.
Oh, but it okay. I had to forcefully.
Yeah. Force grace, you know, grace period, you
know.